so you guys are obviously done uh joint
project together Cube you're part of I
mean we're talking about groups I mean
West Side connection NWA West Side
connection to me was like the first like
super group I mean NWA y'all started
together so I don't consider like y'all
pulling together but Westside Connection
was
a super group for real
um what is for you being a part of of
these group situations or these group
albums that are historical what is the
process like now with Mount Westmore how
different is it I mean I've been with
groups but nobody's been as big as
the group I'm in now of course
you know these guys are Platinum selling
artists that's been in the game over 30
years some 35.
um
and they're Superstars and so you know
with NWA we were all starting together
nobody was a superstar
um Mount Westmore I mean I mean Westside
Connection West Side connection we were
all kind of in the same click and it all
made sense
here uh these are guys that
uh we're friends and it started with a
friendship and respect and 30 years of
admiring each other
into getting a group with those guys
like I feel like um
I can rely on them
you know more than than I even relied in
NWA you know it was a lot of you know
dreads to the [ __ ] now but right back
then it was arguing you know we was
trying to get it right we've seen the
movie yeah so so uh you know it's uh
it's been great to just relax and not
have to you know spearhead everything
and be the the front thinker or the the
one coming up with all the ideas or this
or that you know I'm not saying that I
had to deal with those other groups but
I trust these guys more than I trusted
the other guys because we were kind of
in the trenches together except for
maybe dubsy who's obviously still comes
out on stage
you know we we grew up in the same
neighborhood we grew up rapping against
each other we grew up playing football
against each other the best [ __ ] Walker
of all time yeah you know uh dub is is
amazing
um you know but you know
he
he you know he's a he's an artist that
I'm friends with from from childhood
these are artists that I grew up buying
their records you know dub I help them
put together some of his records so it's
a difference uh I'm a fan of these guys
and uh I wasn't necessarily
just a fan of those guys I was friends
and I like what they do so it's
different and it's easier to be with
superstars than than just guys that you
just put a group together with